you welcome to this video am no gay okay
I don't know rinat be guy f okay I
kicked off with one c4 or change and see
what happens okay this c5 let's go here
and see what we get hmm okay I'm going
to go d for now not g3 which would lead
to a head shock very likely I want to
try this line where there's a quick
opening of the center rb6 hmm that's not
a very common move order is that good
what about this isn't this a problem for
black hmm that looks a bit weird sd-6 is
so weak d 6 that's Bishop f4 that no one
really plays b6 in this position that
this is probably the drawback if they
want to play something like that they
usually start with a six and only later
be 64 head shock type of formation and
so Bishop f4 that basically forces c5
and then I have Bishop g5 I just wonder
if 95 is actually a move here I mean if
he takes it 97 it looks really really
wrong
and 9525 there's a rope hanging on ad
might be an option but ok after it madam
not quite confident if that is really
that great and this really looks nice
what exactly is this means now not not
so clear I mean Bishop e7 Bishop f6 he
has to take with the Jeep on and this
looks like ya like like the worst / Nick
off ever so he will take with the Jeep
honest what is essentially saying I can
also go 95 here which isn't so bad or
queen a form both moves do make some
kind of sense Queen a fourth as possibly
bishops is six ok it's not doing not
doing that much so am I just taking here
let's just take and make sure that he
has to take with the cheap on hmm I
wonder about maybe I still should go
here this is a good idea at this is a
good idea 97 is a threat yeah and this I
mean what exactly after Queen a for you
going Bishop c6 isn't this kind of
tricky why do I just play normal mostly
like g3 Bishop g2 where I think I do
that
this is simple and good I could have
gone queen 84 of course I'm stupid I'm
just stupid Bishop c6 the night is
hanging and there was a threat of 97
double check and made okay so Queenie
for was already already knockout hmm
yeah this was bad that was bad the Queen
a4 is just over i think it would have
been over I mean the position still
sucks for black really but it was a it
was a direct direct end of game I think
you're saying that this changes things
why Queen a forward what is your move
Queen g7 I don't believe it i think i
have bishop h3 then so what is your
defense after Queen a phone I don't see
it I thought you have to go back Bishop
e7 and castle very very quickly I mean
Queen to Queen d7 bishop age three SS
again end of game if it take since 96
double checking the 828 mate so hmm
Bishop's is 6 i'm still picking up the
night on a six and Roxy 697 as well no
improvement
mine 27 Bishop h3 is the end of it
now I could have finished this off what
move earlier but it seems to make no big
difference now and see i played this
rook c8 move yeah you had to do
something about cuneiform I thought we
should be seven and then cancelling
which isn't fun but yeah I actually
think that this whole thing is
unplayable this position I don't think
black is getting out of this even with
perfect play wouldn't be able to get
something decent out of it black resigns
now there's really nothing that you can
do Queen a 4 immediately would have
would have also been completely crushing
ok let's let's go back and do the step
by step um a black mostly in this
position chooses between a couple of
moves I'm bishop before it's one of them
that can easily transpose to a position
after g3 that we normally see from a
limb so Indian this spin is the typical
limbs Oh type of situation or you can
play a six preparing Queen c7 and can
transpose the Sicilian by the way this
is a position that we have seen in the
latest on the Second World Championship
match between cars and a tournant or
black Ingo d5 define phone directly
playing at the center on Lance is sick
so he has a huge range of options I
don't think this is good though because
I'm threatening this and what exactly is
blacks reply I mean if I'm going to be
sick then pick up the bishop pair while
having the dark squares completely under
control where it cannot be good so d6
and now Bishop f4 and this is already
tricky and i think i can go 95 I just
wasn't sure because Bishop g5 is also
excellent
what is the engine giving him okay the
engine wants to play Knight a six now
yeah I wasn't entirely sure this is
really a win it looks terrible black I
mean he doesn't have a single piece out
now okay that was a good alternative
then but this is also very good I mean
I'm threatening this 95 business Bishop
f6 yeah this move cakes digsdigs yeah
the engine is already on plus 2 because
it's it basically says that Black now
has to give up the exchange by playing
Bishop g7 and this Queen a4 is just end
of game he has no move Bishop c6 I was
thinking about this move one move
earlier here but in this situation you
can always block like with this and i
forgot really that the situation is
different now as after Queenie for it
doesn't have a decent block if he goes
Queen d7 chat and winning like this and
well Bishop see six drops this so we
cannot really do anything about this
this discoveries just over okay this is
what I played and now the relatively
best according to the engine is the said
move Bishop b5 but probably has to do it
and then rook c8 that which is
strategically close to being lost but
this is just just what he has to do I
mean on the light squares he's in very
bad shape f5 he for either everything's
week engine is on plus 2 with eco
material and a7 is basically gone so
this and it's still a win it still has
no moves hmm then this is losing quite a
bit check we know that one yeah and
queen d 7 I have I actually that's
stupid right I didn't even see Knight f6
as I mentioned during the video be sure
very that does win of course
yeah I can also just play Knight f6
funny yeah I was what I was calculating
was this line check checkmate and it's
it's enough this is also made by might
make quite a quite a nice one with the
night IAM good cooperation between the
knights and and the Queen yeah so what
to take from that be six is no good that
quick assault on these six is almost the
size of here for wide ok well thanks for
watching